fragst du dich auch täglich hey welcher
promi auf dieser welt sieht mir ähnlich
nein ich glaube ich allerdings ist das
genau das was diese website kann
wir können jetzt beispielsweise nämlich
hier das video von diesem überaus
sportlichen menschen nehmen jetzt werd
ich direkt daran erinnert mal wieder ins
fitnessstudio zu gehen wir können jetzt
einfach auf houston des foto gehen und
jetzt sehen wir dass er
es ist das für ein promi ruben amorim
ich glaube das ist ein fußballspieler
ich habe auch egal heute sollte es
nämlich gar nicht um diese ganzen
beispiel bilder gehen die hier schon
vorhanden sind denn ich habe bilder von
leuten die wir alle kennen rausgesucht
ja geil also ich lade jetzt jemand
eigenes foto hoch und ich verarsche
wer ist denn witzbolde daniel bennett
ist ein us-amerikanischer
eishockeyspieler jahrzehnte wenn ich so
aussehe wie dhl da ich meine auf dem
foto ja ok erkennt man eine ähnlichkeit
aber wahrscheinlich bin ich wieder
dachte er einfach herr lucas so breit
wie ein eishockeyspieler
hier wird auch noch angezeigt dass ich
zu 41% aussehen wie john delbeck what
the [ __ ] allerdings haben wir als
nächste person meine freundin jule gey
judes foto lädt hier auch hoch und sie
liebt das kommt sogar hinten nicola
peltz sie trägt wahrscheinlich oft
pelzmäntel als nächste person wo wir uns
mal anschauen werden was der alster
level look alike ist habe ich meine
lieblings youtuber rausgesucht
ja baby baby bin ich echt gespannt weil
sie einen sehr 9
oh mein gott das passt sie heftig alter
diese person hier sieht mehr aus dass es
ein junge vor allem spencer nicht mehr
aus wie zwei mit des ju finde ich
allerdings machen wir direkt weiter mit
der nächsten person die ich draußen
sucht habe und zwar für eine zweite
katja wäre es jetzt halt über krass wenn
da halt aus
ich kann den namen nicht mal aussprechen
jetcar weil kowar
das passt in die bei dem bild wirklich
nullkommanull allerdings sollte ja gar
nicht hier nur um youtuber gehe nicht
ausgesucht habe sondern ich habe auch
noch dumme genommen
doppel wird ein ganz ganz interessanter
fahrer ich habe mit allem gerechnet aber
nicht mit songbird hier ryanair keine
ahnung hast das essay das ist doch das
weiteste sie zwei leute voneinander
entfernt sein können damit ist korpulent
und weiblich und er ist dünn hat eine
brille und ist männlich hier gerade
bereits gesagt habe ich nicht nur
deutsche youtuber vorbereitete sondern
auch den präsidenten der vereinigten
staaten von amerika donald trump hat
einen sehr eigenen ja ich bin auch so
bescheuert dass ich eine bekannte person
luca machen wir also weiter hat mit
youtube diesmal allerdings nicht mit
einem deutschen youtuber sondern einem
amerikanischen und zwar david gray von
ihm schaue ich mir sehr sehr gern die
videos alles wirklich mit einer meiner
lieblinge man sie
ein gesicht hier gar nicht die anderen
personen sind alex williams in tonys
tell und justin dobyns den haben sie
doch nur wegen dem nachnamen genommen
die beiden haben wir wirklich wieder 0
übereinstimmung wenn man schon david
dobrick nimmt dann darf man natürlich
auch nicht der seine ex-freundin
vergessen und zwar live aus meine lieben
freunde das hier ist ein sehr dunkles
foto das ich von dir ausgewählt haben
also das gut aber das hier wäre das hier
wäre besser also die dna carino wäre
viel besser als diese mia hier vorne
allerdings jetzt zurück in den deutschen
raum der youtuber und zwar habe ich mir
dort ein youtube ausgesuchte der in
letzter zeit ziemlich krass negative
schlagzeilen macht ich glaube jeder weiß
bescheid von wem ich rede montana black
meine lieben zuschauer er ist auch
jemand der eine sehr
das war's wirklich komplett freuen wir
kommen wenn wir nun allerdings auch
schon zur letzten personen die ich uns
für heute vorbereitet habe und was ist
eine person worauf ich wirklich sehr
sehr sehr gespannt bin de wer der
celebrity look alike ist und zwar als
julien beim halt nahezu gar keine leicht
asiatisch aussehenden prominent
huang lee julien hat mit den 52 wirklich
nach donald trump die meisten
übereinstimmung mit seinem celebrity
look alike nuschelt das könnte wirklich
vom gesicht her noch hinkommen aber das
liebe celebs like me website
basically mich dass heute gewinnt jetzt
endlich sauber enden meine lieben
freunde hätte die bock darauf dass ich
so was eventuell nochmal machen mit
bildern von euch die mir dann irgendwie
einsenden könnte oder so dann lasst den
daumen hoch beim video darin schreibt
sie gerne in die kommentare und jetzt
kommt das outro
[Musik]